I'm glad to share that we are now back
with our amazing and affordable don't
memorize Math and Science courses
let me give you five reasons why you
should not miss out on these amazing
courses reason number one get access to
the most engaging videos with real life
applications of Concepts checking are
short chapter summaries will help you
with quick revision third always be exam
ready with mock tests designed as per
the latest exam pattern and syllabus
fourth get your doubts resolved without
any hesitation and last but not the
least you will get to try these highly
curated programs at a starting price of
just rupees 149. so why wait enroll in
these courses and boost your preparation
now